Battles have been won against greater odds. I fought beyond the wall against worse than Ramsay Bolton.
You don't know him.
If I fall. Don't bring me back.
Thousands of men don't need to die.
Only one of us.
hey youtubers. It's Charlie. This is gonna be my episode 9 trailer video.
Battle of the bastards. Bastard Bowl. Snowbowl. Whatever you wanna call it, let's break it down.
There's a couple of very notable things going on here, you may have detected a very Braveheart vibe.
Wherein Jon Snow's / William Wallace's force is very small, totally outmatched by Ramsay's forces.
and I've seen a lot of you real world history buffs hoping that there's a battle of northampton situation
which is basically what happened at the end of Braveheart, where a giant portion of one of the armies
made a secret deal to lay down arms and allow the opposing side through
so a lot of people have hope that part of Ramsay's army will lay down arms and flip sides in the middle of the battle
But if you haven't watched Braveheart in a long time
that happened before the battle started
William Wallace had been on the tear with his army, the had been destroying
all the king's centres of power until this big final battle, where the king made a secret deal with part of Wallace's army
The laid down arms and that's what ultimately lead to Wallace's downfall
So you basically wind up with this giant imbalance  between the size of both armies
Like look at Ramsay's army here, this looks like a much more traditional  formation.
You have rows of archers, you have pikemen, you have mounted soldiers
Just look how deep they are. And then you look at Jon Snow's army, like you see Wun Wun here
running through the foreground, they have some of the wildlings, they have a handful of the Mormonts
and it's really hard to pick out , which banners exactly these are, because the Tv show
has swapped some of the colors on some of the other house's banners
We'll just have to wait till the episode to get better shots of all these.
But using the tv show's logic behind mass transit
I think we can assume that in the episodes we haven't seen Jon Snow and Sansa
that a few more people from the other houses in the north have joined the army
But it's just a handful of people, compared to what Ramsay has
So I think the show wants you to believe that it's a Braveheart situation, we all know how that ended
Jon Snow even tells Melisandre: If I fall in battle, don't bring me back again
So they're just teasing you with this Braveheart situation
when Sansa has gone behind Jon Snow's back to send Littlefinger a letter
I know it wasn't very clear who she was writing to, but there have been  people who have decoded
parts of Sansa's letter. She's basically telling Littlefinger: Ok you're trash but I need your help anyway
So given how melancholic everyone looks on this battlefield, all these dead bodies all over the place
I thinks it's  gonna be an eleventh hour Littlefinger save
but you guys can let me know. Do you think that Sansa wrote to Littlefinger that was the secret letter,
because she wasn't writing to the Blackfish.
She had already sent Brienne to get the Blackfish's help
before she sent the other letter in a more recent episode.
so the person she was writing to was different from  the Blackfish.
So given that , do you think she was asking for Littlefinger's help?
And he'll come riding in just in time to save our precious characters.
But not before a ton of people end up dying.
And I know a lot of you have wondered if in the background, some of these figures are the night's king.
or white walkers. If they're going to walk in and interrupt the battle
I am not expecting that twist, because I think we'll follow up with them through Bran's storyline.
So unless we see Bran in this episode, I am not expecting to see white walkers.
south of the wall. I think the surprise is gonna be the knights of the vale
But the bother big question, because there isn't any other footage besides this battle of the bastards in the trailer
Is: will we see Daenerys and the second siege of Meereen ?
Or are they gonna save that for the last episode. Even though Hardhome was a massive episode last season
they still touched on a couple other storylines. Even though they spent most of the episode up at Hardhome.
So I think that might be the case here. Where most of the episode takes place at the battle of Winterfell
But they briefly touch on the other storylines.  So even if we don't get to see Daenerys
release the other two dragons, till episode ten. I think they'll at least touch briefly on that storyline.
And then we also have Cersei and the promise of a mad queen- situation with  wildfire.
If they don't touch on that, then they'll be saving that for episode ten.  But I love how we've all
been joking about Daenerys mad queen, when we should really be talking about
Cersei mad queen. Even though technically she's the queen mother
But here's my other big question for you guys. Let me know
Do you feel like it's going to be SnowBowl episode 9 and then it's going to be fire in episode 10.
Because we have Cersei wildfire, that might be happening. And we have  Daenerys' dragons vs. the great masters
So there are a couple of big battles. Some of them involving fire, some of them taking place
in the frozen north. but that's to say nothing of what Bran is going to do.
when the night's king army reaches the wall.
That's like  a completely separate situation  than from what's going on here at Winterfell.
So prepare for them to touch on that briefly.  So many they have to resolve that I'll be interested to see
what they leave out of episode 9. Because there are at least 3 big battles coming ahead.
4 if you count Bran vs. the Night's king.  but my next big video is gonna be
my Q&A from episode 8. I'm happy to answer questions about episode 9, too.
So just  leave all your questions on this. There's a new round of giveaways  that is still going on.
All you have to do to enter is be subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I'll just announce the winner , whenever I post that Q&A video.
So that'll be either Tuesday or Wednesday.
I feel like if you thought episode 8 was lackluster, this is the answer to that.
So just pitch battle an entire episode. It's gonna be so much fun.
While you guys wait for my next video to post, you can klick here for last night's  episode 8 video.
And you can click here for a tower of joy, R+L=J refresher
If you guys don't know what that's all about.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody, let's high five.
I'll see you guys tonight.